the acting FBI director also says many
administration talking points on commis
firing are inaccurate Andrew McCabe took
commis place at a Senate Intelligence
Committee hearing yesterday questions
about the FBI shake-up and Russia
investigation dominated the hearing
Nancy Cordes is on Capitol Hill with the
latest on that Nancy good morning good
morning well if the president was hoping
that he'd get a friendlier FBI with
Comey gone Andrew McCabe shattered those
hopes yesterday he directly refuted
several White House talking points about
commis firing and made it clear that the
Russia investigation will not be stopped
director McCabe welcome to the table and
into the fray commis former deputies
suddenly at the helm disputed the white
house claim that FBI rank-and-file
wanted Comey gone no sir
that is not accurate director Comey
enjoyed broad support within the FBI and
still does to this day McCabe also cast
doubt on president Trump's claim that
Comey had assured him three times he was
not under investigation I'm not aware of
that being a standard practice as for
White House claims that the FBI's
investigation into Russian influence is
a minor probe it is all investigation in
relation to all to all the other work
that you're doing
sir we consider it to be a highly
significant investigation so far
Republicans have resisted democratic
calls for a special prosecutor how is
this not obstruction of justice but the
shifting stories from the White House
are putting pressure on the GOP if the
president has made contradictory
statements that have been up to the
President to to to explain himself
late Thursday Senate Majority Leader
Mitch McConnell invited fpg Attorney
General Rod Rosenstein to brief senators
on p'omise firing next week at the
urging of his Democratic counterpart
Chuck Schumer this investigation will
not die no matter who wants it - Rosen
Stein was actually here on Capitol Hill
yesterday for a long-planned meeting
with the leaders of the Senate
Intelligence Committee they're
discussing ways to avoid having these
two
doing investigations now one at the FBI
one here in the Senate from interfering
with one another Charlie thanks Nancy